[Music]
when I was choosing my my GCSEs felt
like a whole list and said like
photography so I picked it and then I
kind of started taking on my phone then
kind of posting pitches and my dad kind
of surprised me with the camera I prefer
black and white and portrait photography
but I don't really like take the
pictures of three phases I like old you
know interesting faces so black and
white I think brings out the contour I
don't really ask take pictures of people
I kind of just get in their face so some
people hate it some peeps find it funny
I bought my first camera at a vintage
camera store can't remember its name
[Music]
my favorite photographer is Steven
myself but I really like like Peter
Lindbergh David Sims Bruce Weber in the
future I really want to do more more
stuff light exists in my work but I got
asked to do one with Christy's for my
book that's coming out I've been working
on for more than a year now it's been a
long thing to work but it's really nice
and I really hoped I could do more
exhibiting my work
I really like the streetscape I don't
really skate at eight o'clock London
when I lived in LA like five years ago
time the skate parks and that's kind of
where I started skateboarding my
favorite places are here in LA
I'm ascared at The Berrics yeah which is
in LA I haven't skated I will
[Music]
you